una intervención esperada en la asamblea
general de la ONU el ministro de
exteriores rusos sergei labrov acusó a
occidente del odio generalizado hacia
Rusia
la rusofobia oficial en occidente ha
alcanzado una escala grotesca sin
precedentes no escatimaman en declarar
su intención de infligir una derrota
militar a nuestro país pero también de
destruir y fracturar a Rusia
además aprovechó para defender la guerra
en Ucrania que inició el 24 de febrero
la incapacidad de los países
occidentales para negociar y la continua
guerra del régimen de kiev contra su
propio pueblo no nos dejaron otra opción
la dependencia sobre la República
Popular de donés y Iniciar una operación
militar especial para proteger al pueblo
Ruso y a otros pueblos del dumbas en su
discurso la broma arremetió contra las
decisiones de política internacional de
Washington por ejemplo la independencia
de Taiwán y les advirtió que jugaban con
fuego china en su intervención reiteró
los derechos que dice tener sobre la
isla
desde la antigüedad Taiwán ha sido una
parte inseparable del territorio de
China la soberanía y la integridad
territorial de China nunca han sido
cortadas y el hecho de que la parte
continental y Taiwán pertenezcan a una
misma china nunca ha cambiado todos los
chinos nunca hemos dejado de esforzarnos
por realizar la reunificación en cuanto
a la guerra en Ucrania el ministro de
exteriores chino dijo que su país apoya
a los esfuerzos para buscar una
resolución pacífica del conflicto